[Música]
bueno guys habló un poquito fuerte como
lo están pasando hoy
creo que también vamos a repetirlo con
un poquito más de fuerza a ver cómo lo
estamos pasando hoy
bien pues para que mañana puedan contar
lo bien que lo están pasando como
comentaba ayer hay hemos decidido hacer
un resumen a través de los emo jeans los
emo jeans son aquellos muñequitos estas
son tan simpáticos que hasta mi madre lo
utiliza para hablar con whatsapp con mi
hermana la primera charla que tuvimos
hoy fue ruth aramayo se acuerdan nos
hablaba del poder de la música y es que
cuando yo pienso en música y en mi
infancia siempre me recuerda a esta
canción les suena
bien quien sepa la canción que la cante
conmigo dice algo así como en un país
multicolor
la acción abeja bajo el sol la nana
hasta aquí y es que la música tiene el
poder de transmitir las emociones de
alegría tristeza o prepararnos para la
batalla también ruth les dijo oye y si
ponemos la película 50 sombras de gray
en el colegio que les parece casi todos
pusieron esta cara alguna persona dijo
alguna palabra que no puedo decir y
también nos recordó la canción del
verano de 2017
gracias root llevo dos días cantando
lado y me levanta a las siete y media de
la mañana cantando la y es la canción de
despacito nos la sabemos todos y todas
verdad sí o no la cantamos si dice algo
así como despacito quiero desnudar tu
ropa a besos despacito firmar las
paredes de tu laberinto y hacer de tu
cuerpo a todo un manuscrito
[Música]
que le enseñes a mi boca sus lugares
favoritos los favoritos favoritos baby
quiero sobrepasar tus zonas de peligro
hasta provocar tus gritos y que olvides
tu apellido
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos a hacerlo en una playa en puerto
rico hasta que las olas grite no no no a
ver vamos a ponernos en la situación que
esto es puerto rico
esto es la arena ustedes son las olas
aquí viene daddy yankee luis fonsi y
dicen josé vamos a hacerlo vale entonces
ustedes tienen que gritar en plan ay
bendito súper fuerte vale
empezamos de nuevo desde el despacito
vale
[Aplausos]
vamos a hacerlo en una playa en puerto
rico hasta que las olas griten
ahora sí muy crack pero más crack
luisito sigues por aquí
soy tu fan soy tu fan y el fan de todos
esos pequeños y pequeñas que nos han
venido del colegio rey juan carlos
primero dejémoslo en juan carlos primero
porque creo que ya no es rey
que estos alumnos y alumnas nos han
venido de la isla de enfrente de gran
canarias y porque son unos cracks porque
ellos sólo han sido capaces de producir
de cargarse de la iluminación escribir
el guión y a partir de interpretarlo
también se acuerdan del juego del
teléfono siempre falla vamos al final no
hay nadie que aceptará la palabra o la
frase que habíamos dicho al principio y
al final su obra trataba más o menos de
lo mismo verdad de los malos entendidos
que cree estar mirando en el móvil sobre
toda la pareja de estar en plan de
cotillas o de estar poniendo a la oreja
que eso nos gusta mucho luego vino
antonio acosta algunos nos hizo que lo
pudiéramos oír a otro nos hizo que no
nos pudiéramos ver y él decía que es la
hora de que la sordoceguera sea una
particularidad particularidad única y es
que el mundo de las personas sordociegas
termina donde terminan sus manos pero
tranquilo nos ha dado la solución si
encontramos a una persona que sordociega
es tan fácil como poder escribirle las
letras en las palmas de su mano o no es
verdad
muy bien se acuerdan de los cortos que
vimos de tenerife noir en canario cómo
sería
tenerife noir de toda la vida vale pero
esto no quiere decir que no vengan a
tenerife jaja der bengala tenerife
porque hay un festival de género negro
con talento canario luego tuvimos la
charla de angélica das donde las hablaba
de la belleza de la piel verdad a que
ninguno nos gusta tener un pacto con
leche al final de verano todos
preferimos el pan tom chocolate sexy
verdad perfecto yo lo tengo más o menos
así luego josé díaz nos vino y nos habló
de la relación que hay entre las
emociones y los colores y ahí seguí
emociones básicas que no son capaces de
entendernos en massachusetts en pekín o
en bratislava y esas emociones son
alegría tristeza miedo y da asco como
muchos detienen a la canción de
despacito o sorpresa también
me gustaría que todos conocieran a
través del hashtag de x la laguna
eligieran una emoción y la compartieran
a través del twitter o del instagram y
así vamos a ver al final del evento qué
emoción es la que la ha transmitido tdx
la laguna
también llegó aquí dijo todo el mundo
manos arriba hay más de uno salió
corriendo porque pensó que era la
policía pero no lo que nos quería sacar
en una foto térmica nada más que al
final terminaron siendo dos y también
nos habló de la importancia de entender
que en cada país o en cada parte del
mundo los colores los entendemos de
manera diferente o tienen diferente
asociación por ejemplo en occidente el
negro es el color del luto mientras que
en oriente es el color blanco
aquí nos pusimos nerviosos verdad dinero
en los compañeros de la cruz roja que
están allí llegaron
pauli viene porque había una persona que
tenía bradicardia sabe lo que es
bradicardia
levante la mano a la gente vale no es un
infarto al corazón que me salta en el
cuello
bradicardia es cuando la persona tiene
menos de 60 pulsaciones por minuto
entonces estaban pablo y viene aquí por
favor trata de arrancarlo venid ya voy
pablo ii
perdón pero
el golpe fue bueno es viviana entiendo
lo que viviste antes
viviana es esa mujer que parece que cayó
del espacio donde viene la fija ver aquí
el error no existe
hay alguien en la sala que se lo sepa
todo
no verdad entonces si el error no existe
y no hay un conocimiento pleno
viviana nos invita a que seamos capaces
de crearnos o imaginarnos nuestra
nuestra propia realidad yo creo que le
pondría unicornios dragones y heroína
porque me molaría o no
aparte también hay que tener en cuenta
que la educación nos ha enseñado a no
creer en la magia y esto lo siento por
los fan de harry potter como soy yo o
como es mi hermana también luego vino
amalia se acuerdan
si no lleva mal yen y saber son lo mismo
unas tetas en canarias que unas tetas en
pekín y todo se pone caliente la cosa
pero no no fue así al final decía y
alguien mis labios son súper sexys pero
mi todo no o también es verdad que hay
un montón de países donde ver una mujer
con una falda por encima de la rodilla a
más de uno lo vuelve muy loco con trump
bueno nos ha enseñado la sociedad a que
tenemos que elegir entre ser hombres o
mujeres y que no podemos ser ninguna de
las dos cosas a la vez ni a veces nos
podemos querer sentir hombres y otras
veces querer no sentir mujer
y es que amalia sueña con un mundo donde
la gente no nos mire raro si a veces
queremos ser del género femenino
masculino si no queremos tener ningún
género o nos queremos sentir los que nos
dé la gana
hace poco hace nada estuvieron aquí
lucia y carolina la verdad disfrutamos
un montón e hicieron bailar nuestros
corazones son dos cantautoras canarias
que han unido sus voces y desde hace
mucho tiempo nos llevan haciendo
disfrutar aquí en canarias
yeray preguntaba si había algún salto
nico en la sala yo conozco a uno alguien
más puede levantar la mano
vale juancho levanta la mano este es el
que conozco que es el tónico
bueno lo siento te quiero
no se preocupen los daltónicos porque no
le pasó lo mismo el nacido y no veían
los colores entonces lo que decidió fue
conectar la tecnología a su cuerpo y
desde entonces los pueden oír por lo
cual para el próximo tv x para que
puedan ver el logo en color rojo les
invito a que hablen conmigo y por lo
menos puedan escuchar el color del logo
de esta charla luego vino manuel maynar
él hablaba de que los videojuegos es un
nuevo concepto en la educación del siglo
21 y yo aplaudía así
ojalá yo hubiera estado en el colegio
jugando a los videojuegos y más de uno y
de una también les hubiera gustado
verdad y aunque parecen parezca
increíble hay muchas voces que están en
contra y que les enfada que los
videojuegos formen parte de la educación
y es una realidad que los videojuegos
pueden ayudar tanto en la parte
sanitaria como una persona que se siente
sola y que pueda estar mucho mejor y el
problema no está en los videojuegos en
que nos podamos sentir gordos como papá
noel ya que por ejemplo en japón que es
uno de los países que están más viciados
así tener los ojos ellos tienen la tasa
de obesidad más una de las tasas de
obesidad más baja que hay en el mundo
luego vino ana gallardo dijo un montón
de palabras que si no se enteraron de
las cosas que dijo al principio si
ustedes no van paseando el perrito por
la calle mientras les sacan un vídeo si
no tienen conectado al señor roca es
decir la taza del váter al móvil a la se
pregunta para qué están en este mundo y
es que es indudable que la evolución
tecnológica ha traído cosas
y mejores también y al final hay un
problema y es que en un mundo se tiene
que saber adaptar al igual que lo han
hecho los caballos y los los
rinocerontes para poder llegar a ser
unicornios obviamente nos podemos quedar
con dos conceptos de la charla de anna
uno es el nativo digital y otra vez el
inmigrante digital y es que para poder
salvar o escalar las diferencias que hay
entre estas dos generaciones es
importante que exista una solidaridad
entre los nativos digitales y los
inmigrantes digitales también para
terminar st fusión st funciones un grupo
con una gran mezcla cultural satomi que
viene desde japón
el canario tomás miguel que viene desde
colombia y aquí ahora que viene desde
tenerife sin más espero que mañana sean
capaces de recordar el evento es decir
la quinta edición
dt de x la laguna y lo puedan compartir
con toda la gente que les rodea muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]